government officials are bracing for
more election-related protests at this
hour we've already seen demonstrations
in a handful of cities correspondent
david lee miller shows us tonight
from new york
we're here in philadelphia thursday
dueling demonstrations were held outside
the pennsylvania convention center where
ballots are being counted
pro-biden protesters outnumbered
supporters of the president
the two sides separated by barricades
were peaceful
wednesday night in phoenix hundreds of
the president's supporters rallied
outside the maricopa county election
center
the group criticized the decision by fox
news to call the state for joe biden
demonstrators say the president can
still win the state
and demanded a fair count
trump backers also protested outside a
ballot counting facility in detroit
angry demonstrators banged on windows
demanding to be let inside
to observe the count in new york city a
pro-biden demonstration turned violent
we are in the streets right now because
we want equality for everyone more than
50 people were arrested
including this woman who after screaming
at an nypd
sergeant spit in his face
in portland oregon an anti-trump protest
erupted into violence
protesters threw bottles and broke
windows in minneapolis
hundreds of mostly peaceful protesters
blocked traffic on i-94
they marched to voice opposition against
president trump
as well as racial inequality
and here in new york city like elsewhere
in the country police are preparing for
more protests
that could turn violent the governors of
at least
10 states have now activated the
national guard
to if necessary assist local law
enforcement
brett david lee miller
thank you